c'est pour ça que je voulais parler ça
parce que vous me disiez un peu plus
libérale sur le plan national un cadre
assez atypique pour cette réunion de
campagne de la liste réinventant
elancourt
objectif présenter les grandes lignes de
son programme en petit comité et ainsi
mieux répondre aux questions des
citoyens
il ya des idées que nous nous n'avions
pas eu et qui nous sont venues des
habitants comme par exemple dire que le
quotient familial est particulièrement
injuste et qu'il faut absolument le
rendre plus juste plus évolutif
voir par exemple ce qui s'est passé à la
clé de saint pierre avec le fait que le
dernier médecin de la clé saint pierre
va peut être partir ça c'est arrivé en
cours de campagne
donc notre projet a été extrêmement
évolutif cette liste de gauche qui se
veut participative propose un projet
alternatif en trois axes majeurs un
projet social et solidaire un engagement
pour la transition écologique et de la
démocratie participative
j'ai fait le choix de venir participer à
la réunion aujourd'hui parce que je suis
déjà impliqué dans une dans une
association à l'échelle à l'échelle de
notre résidence et le projet
m'intéressait puisque il le reprend les
le côté le côté associatif et et vie
locale les éléments forts de réinventer
le recours sont pour moi effectivement
tout cette volonté de rechercher le
vivre ensemble le respect mutuel
l'humanisme organisé cette réunion chez
moi
aujourd'hui il ya une semaine élection
était une manière effectivement deux pas
de concrétiser encore plus loin ce
travail la prochaine réunion pour la
liste réinventons elancourt le jeudi 12
mars à 20h30 à la maison de quartier de
la ville dieu en présence de benoît
hamon